make sure y'all check me out bootleg Kev
podcast bing bong
Le cat podcast special guest in here
representing Philly yes sir my guy Ines
man welcome bro you already know king of
battle rap the king of battle rap what
makes you freestyles what makes you the
king of battle rap right I've been doing
it before battle leagues was Battle
leagues that's why I'm a king of battle
rap before they start uh made it a
corporate thing and brought it into the
building and kind of monetized it I was
I was Battle rapping that's how I mean
what is it about Philly man that the
battle rap hit is just so like
you know I feel like you guys are just
like a walking Smack DVD out there yeah
man it's real the coach is real heavy
out there it's um there's a
Commonwealth's City so it's like State
and it's just like real competitive and
we all bunched in together it's like
real houses it stores people on top of
people so the competitiveness is real
heavy so when it comes to battle rap
it's real aggressive and sometimes it
gets spill out into the street I
technically technically was in Philly
once okay but it was only because I rode
the train through from DC
but they did stop there was like a stop
in Chester and I looked out the window
Chester Pennsylvania looks like it might
be the worst place on the planet no it
is it's real bad I remember just looking
out the window on my train
and there was like two like kids just in
the streets running around and I
remember being like I'm like a third
world country put my maps on I said
Chester and then I Googled it and I was
like oh it's lit out here it is lit
shout out to Chester man I need to get
out to Philly hey what is the cause I
always hear if you go to Philadelphia
that there is like the Taurus
Cheesesteak spot but then there's like
the real spot right well Max Max's is
like the spot where you want to go to
get a real authentic cheese steak Gino's
is the The Tourist Spots so don't go to
genos
I'm not going
belittle any landmark in Philly right
right what I'm into but I'm just saying
a little overrated yeah if you want to
go get authentic Cheesesteak go to Max's
ordinary
it's almost like when people come to LA
and they expect roscos to be like the
best food they've eaten and it's like
guys it's just not come here that's what
they say like bro you want to go to
Roscoe I'm like it's okay but I've been
coming out here since the early 2000s so
I'm like over the like yeah like the
first time being out here type so
everybody want to come that come out L.A
they want to go to ride schools but and
it's all right yeah I'm saying um but if
you've been into Atlanta and glad it's
just the same thing or if you go to
Arizona go to Lolo's Chicken and Waffles
I would argue to say it's the best
chicken and waffle spot I've ever had
shout out to lolos for sure
um when did you feel like the battle rap
because like you're I feel like you're
really in your bag right now when it
comes to like being looked at as like
one of the elite guys in that world like
when do you feel like you kind of had
hit your stride in terms of getting your
respect in that world because it's like
a very
it's like almost like a
I feel like you could be a die-hard
hip-hop head and not know what the going
on in the battle rap world because they
are so different and it is like such a
sub-genre of it's almost like we have to
be baptized in the battle rap culture
now you have to go through something you
have to have the near-death experience
or come close to dying from them to even
sanctify you as being anybody that has
any validity of saying anything or
speaking about battle rap coach it's
that intense right so that's why I don't
speak on it yeah so with that being said
um it's a high regard for battle rappers
and their accountability so over the
weekend it was a battle rap it was a
battle big battle League you were here I
was here for that so it was the
ownership battle League which in the
main event being a king Bob versus
Daylight they like being a residential
West Coast so yeah that's a beast so
shot them they like and we are from the
same battle rap click which is dot me
T-rex murder moot uh daylight Jesus big
cannon real deal so that's a serious
screw yeah you guys are like the NWO
yeah and I got a lot of flack from that
from being from Philly and being that as
a New York based click but the
Daylight's from LA right so it's all
over there yeah is there other clicks
like that yeah you got gun titles you
got uh uh The Goonies which is ahead
about twerk uh you got gun titles which
was kind of like coke coke co-founded by
uh Tay Rock and super Surfers
yeah so yeah you got a little like
clicks Dark Side you got a uh brizz
rosting and T-top so it's like little
sub clicks and yo what's the name of our
guy rum knitties from Phoenix right he's
from he's from Phoenix XZ he's down with
a uh uh uh
my badge you got to get you Gotti and
him are called uh uh every bar efb I
like that see all this like I know the
names but bro I'm not in tune with the
battleship like that I just feel like I
don't have the bandwidth to like learn
this like when I was a kid I used to
download the battles on Napster yeah
like when it was like Supernatural and
Juice yeah those those guys is like
almost like ancient artifacts compared
to where it's at now it's so special and
then I would no disrespecting those guys
they are the gods of this with the
freestyling off the top of the dome
right right in the room and all that
you're in the crowd it's different it's
not as different as this brand it's got
wavy hair dreadlocks baldies there's
[__] members his blood members it's
intense it's Latin King well no and then
like there was like The Smack DVD era
and like I got my name because I used to
sell a bunch of bootleg mixtapes and and
DVDs and [__] at the swap meet so I was
like The Smack DVD errors are probably
the the highest like peak of me being
like super engaged and then obviously I
know who's killing it like I know
yourself I know Murder mooc sues my
boy's incredible uh yeah there's there's
guys that especially Loaded Lux you know
all these guys of course there are
legends that if you're a part of the
culture you have to know who they are
I'm just not I haven't bro I've watched
a few like in the last year but like
when there's these big events I feel
like I'll just catch the highlights on
Twitter right right so battle rap
it's like a um it's like a revolving
door so you're only good as your last
battle and if you don't do very well
they put you in a box so I mean if you
don't do other things to uh to to
complete it's like to to pose that so I
went and built the whole leverage on the
other side of the spectrum with my music
right reintroducing myself as an artist
and reading and creating myself always
into the play and putting out a new
project where I got the battle rap
culture and I got take rock on there I
got Method Man I got Benny The Butcher I
got a a a a a vato Corey Guns Beanie
Siegel freeway right I got all the like
the top spitters on my drone so I use
that the leverage and the buzz that I
built with my freestyles on social media
and the content and uh and and the
projects and the material I was putting
out outside of bad rep to leverage
battle rap to get the bigger bags and
the bigger looks because once you lose
in the eyes of the culture they put you
in a certain box and it's like boxing so
you gotta climb back up the ranks until
you get to the top brass and compete
with like the top tier guys and if you
got the catalog you got the music
outside of it it's almost like it was
would it would behoove them to not
include you and [__] because you got a
fan base you you running it up on your
own you know what I'm saying for sure
and Shout out I mean a lot there is
there is a a stereotype and I don't know
how true it is or not but back in the
day there used to be a lot of the guys
who did battle rap weren't great at
making records I mean that's the number
one stigma and I I was the guy who
bridged that guy right I was one of the
first guys who started out battle
rapping on the corners of Philadelphia
and then in front of the Chinese stores
and stuff like that and actually took it
corporate and made an album and came out
with a full-fledged album and yeah I
mean was able to you know go like walk
on Take a Walk on both sides right and
still having a seed planted in battle
rap coach as well as like mainstream I
mean releases and stuff like that
because at 2008 when I battled my son
World Series of hip-hop I was still
currently signing bad boy and was like
currently like like back then a
recording for my for my solo release my
son shout out to myself so yeah so like
that's how far go back and that was
before smack was created at that event
smack was the actual cameraman he was
hired to do a service so now look at
them now to where they're full-fledged
company and got the caffeine deal and
all the things they got going on so I
was a part of that I'm a part of those
building blocks and I just don't get my
credit but I embrace that fact so that's
why I'm here still 20 years later
beating these young opponents up beating
a new competition up getting there with
the youngins letting them know that I
got that's considered some would say
pastor's promise still got enough in the
tank to get in there and destroy These
Guys these young cats hey we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about the homies at mybookie bet on
anything anywhere anytime at mybookie.ag
and check this out if you sign up right
now with the keyword bootleg you're
gonna get a first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and that's not it
if you sign up with that keyword bootleg
not only will you get that first deposit
bonus up two thousand dollars but you're
also gonna get a free 50 000 sweet 16
bracket entry so many ways to win at
mybookie.ag I've been using them for
about 10 years now trust me when I say
I'm not co-signing them because they're
dropping the bag I mean that's nice but
I've been literally using my bookie for
the better part of the last decade to
put all my sports bets in to play a
little online roulette a little black
jack a little craps it's all there they
got the live casino they got so much
going on look March Madness is where
it's at right now you can get down with
that uh sweet 16 the elite eight the
NCAA Final Four all of it NBA season in
full effect baseball is about to kick
off get in on the action bet on anything
anytime anywhere right now with my
bookie so sign up at mybookie.ag use
that promo code bootleg right now for
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and a free 50 000 sweet
16 bracket entry hey also shout out to
the homies at Bluetooth man don't forget
if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction in if your penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather Bluetooth is where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and scialis but
it's in a chewable form all right it is
sent right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife Weaver never know it even happened
you know what I'm saying maybe you've
been a little embarrassed you're tired
of piping down that same old bra that
you've been sleeping with for the last
35 years put a little pep in your step
man take a Bluetooth use that promo code
bootleg bluetooth.com and try it for
free uh you linked up with Kanye last
year how did that how did that first of
all that's a big big connect I remember
you were supposed to come on the show
and he was like bro I'm with Kanye right
now I was like don't even even worry
about it you even sent me a pic I was
like bro I believe you don't worry about
it yeah no because everybody you know
um I just want to start by saying uh I
knew Kanye for over 25 years way before
he you know what I'm saying I always
knew what he was going to do yeah I know
always when he was different and um just
just short story
um we had a mutual friend playing Pat
and Ferris Bueller yeah there was
Executives over Def Jam I mean Pat what
up yeah
so uh you know we would have mutual
friends and uh during like during the
recording process other making the band
album I invited them to the to the crib
recording Soho at the Double Brownstone
by chance Mr Bentley said we couldn't
have no company so I had to tell Kanye
he couldn't come in and submit beats and
then two years later Mr Bentley signed
to good music that's so hilarious I
forgot that he got signed I forgot
Diddy's assistant had a record deal and
put out some records yep so that was
crazy I always uh me and fines are worth
always laugh about this remember when
you didn't let Kanye in and now you're
signed him that shit's hilarious so me
and Kanye had a relationship and by my
Instagram uh presence and just dropping
freestyles and being consistent he seen
what he knows he Styles he said yo
you've been my bro for a minute could
come out and gave me an open invitation
to come you know some writing sessions
with them yeah so I saw that uh you know
there was the I don't know if that
documentary's ever going to come out but
he was previewing a record and you were
saying that you were on that record with
him and Soulja Boy yeah uh well I did
some references so he was actually
hearing me playing a reference off my
phone for him in the footage so he was
both in the car and you know I forgot we
was being take because he's being taped
filmed all day long if you're like
helping yay right what is it where what
mind state do you have to be in if
you're like I have to help the group
like one of the greatest artists of all
time
um
it was just
it's not like working for Diddy working
for Diddy is like real so okay so
everybody asked me why I put out so much
material on why I'm so it seems like me
it's an easy transition for me to keep
putting out these constant freestyles
well when I came up in a bad boy system
they used to make us write five verses
for every verse so if we was doing a
three verse song I would have to write
five verse 15 verses per song wow so and
then you pick the best one yeah which
usually is the first [__] verse you
wrote right so from there you're like so
I got 13 extra I got 14 extra verses
just just just
unused unused do you still do that yeah
um every now and then well back in the
mixtape games with mixtapes were hurry I
would take the uh the uh um the DJ
sycamores and all the all those type of
guys so how no matter whether I like the
beat or not and this is what I got from
Diddy this is one of the lessons I got
from Diddy he was like this is not
writing about the writing to the beats
that you don't like he's not Bob right
to the beach that you do like try right
into the beach that you don't like so
then when you hear a beat that you do
like it's like [__] it's like water
yeah so I take a I take every beat off
the beat CD and write a 16 to it no
matter whether I like it or not hey
that's how you sharpen your your pen for
real because if you can write to some
[__] you don't [__] with then if you
start writing for somebody else and they
might not be in your bag endless supply
material so when I do go do these
writing sessions it's not me physically
after the right now I'm just pulling
[__] out I'm just pulling ideas out from
from everywhere wow yeah that's that's
crazy uh you got the new project out
sure is this a mixtape this is a mixtape
shut up everybody I know everything is
digitized I'm kind of one of those guys
that's like coming into the new fruition
of the where where is that so is this on
Spotify yes we we're trying to get that
up and running now but uh this is what I
was everywhere your boy says it's
everywhere but
as as an artist that's been around has
been seasoned I didn't come in like come
into the game around you know this era
right so me and my team we still in
under construction figuring we got to
get a distro kit account it's that easy
no it's that easy it's that easy he's
like bro we got it but
everybody that's sick why you got that
don't make yourself sound like a
dinosaur right now you're not a no I'm
not a dinosaur but I want to tell you
this is for the Nostalgia yo let me tell
you this is literally how I made my
whole entire
this is that's what I'm saying so for
all the hip-hop Heads This is not that I
outdated this is for the nostalgic
feeling of mixtapes listen I used to go
to this the actual hard copy and I used
to buy these Bible cases and burn these
CDs and print these covers in my parents
bedroom
yep so this is not saying I'm outdated
this is paying homage to where I came
from physical products yeah physical
real fans can support So eating that's
the friends enes and friends I got bitty
the butcher which is the first single
Trifecta I got the single uh featuring
zazos and DJ crazy
um um uh this that was then and this is
now got the Blinky out Corey Guns Beanie
Siegel Vado and who's who Tay Rock being
like it's just like all spitters all
spiders who's you um if we're talking
about the Mount Rushmore of Philly
rappers who's on it man excluding
yourself Beanie Sigel has to go there
Meek Milly has to go there
those are the black shorts yeah those
are the three right and then the fourth
one's kind of yeah it could be freeway
it could be yeah
so I got those three at the top but you
need one more
it's Mount Rushmore there's four people
schooly day schooly D the oh gee I like
it that's like the OG era yeah yeah
Black Thought is like one of the most
prolific uh thought lyrics is ever man
yeah crazy hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at Odd Socks baby that's
right shout out to Odd Socks little
Godfather sock right there craziest
licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws pop these boys open
check them out oh yeah oh yeah a little
Chun Lee versus Blanco
what
amazing
do you like you who so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
Yoo-hoo they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet I promise
you you gotta go to autotoxofficial.com
right now and use the promo code bootleg
save 20 off your entire order alright so
go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Jardin the craziest
dispenser you've ever walked into in
your life Harding Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview
um all right so that's how people can go
get it and I got the cheesecake too so I
turn lemon into eliminate let me speak
about that too because I always but I
gotta throw it in I was trying to go the
whole interview without talking now but
you gotta feel tired of it yeah I am
tired of it but I'm not never talking
money from yeah so listen you have your
own cheesecake and what year was making
the band 2002 Jesus so in 2002 Making
the Band was uh one of the best reality
shows ever the most iconic episode is
when you guys had to walk to Juniors yes
for cheesecake yeah very humbling
experience yeah lesson being learning
everything it's not about what you want
to do it's about what needs to be done
to get the job done and you have your
own cheesecake I have my own cheesecake
is it good yes it is how can they get it
follow me on Instagram
Nest cheesecake at
n-e-s-s-c-h-e-e-s-e-c-a-k-e is that
something people have to be in Philly to
purchase uh you could purchase it
offline we trying to get the deal with
it
oh you you got to get the kid the ghost
kitchen and we got the we got the boxes
with the with the with the like the
refrigeration built in with it oh listen
all you got to do is get a ghost kitchen
situation ghost kitchen got to put me up
okay have you ever opened up Postmates
and seen that like DJ Khaled has a
restaurant or like Tyga or Wiz Khalifa
have like their own restaurants like in
every city you go to okay what it is is
you you'll you'll hire a ghost kitchen
so let's say you're in LA or you're in
New York or wherever you think you got a
big following right
you find a commercial kitchen that does
Postmates or GrubHub [__] and then you
have you have a restaurant virtually
online in all those cities and this
kitchen handles the Fulfillment they're
pretty much licensing your likeliness to
sell your cheesecake okay but they cook
it they have the real estate the receipt
you give them the pay they just they
just essentially give you a cut to use
your likeliness oh wow put me on so now
you like like if you open like Postmates
right now you'll see like DJ Khaled has
a restaurant Postmates I got you got you
so he doesn't have a restaurant but he
just they just selling his product
they're giving they they're using his
likeness to sell 100 gotcha yeah it's
kind of like
a lot of people are doing the ghost
kitchen waves and just to clean it up
the album is everywhere digitally on all
everywhere it's on Spotify it's on Apple
music Spotify Apple music and it might
be at a bodega in Philly somewhere
there it is all right man we'll look
yo new YouTube video with the freestyle
so check it out appreciate you pulling
up brother when's the next battle award
rbear ARP that's versus a ward stay
tuned when is it I don't know I was
supposed to be on the May 10th card ARP
Holla At Me
do you battle people who are your
friends ever always I bet on my [__]
grandmother if the check is right I like
it there it is so I want no smoke man
eating this appreciate you brother